[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem donnerstag die vom sport hat
norbert lehmann einen rollator von mir
und das sind die themen von heute
front oder flucht während in russland
die ersten reservisten nach der
mobilmachung eingezogen werden verlassen
andere in letzter minute das land
ein zeichen setzen der un-sicherheitsrat
will den druck auf moskau erhöhen
präsident lee lenski pocht auf eine
gerechte bestrafung
protestwelle in iran der tod einer 22
jährigen treibt weiter tausende auf die
straßen 17 menschen sterben bei
demonstrationen gegen das regime
die erste russische kriegs mobilisierung
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg läuft
offiziell ist es nur eine
teilmobilmachung
300.000 von angeblich 25 millionen
reservisten sollen in der ukraine
kämpfen aber die unruhe in der
russischen bevölkerung ist groß in fast
jeder familie gibt es reservisten und es
ist nicht klar wer eingezogen wird anton
kuh schicken hat mehr sie ziehen in den
krieg russische reservisten
verabschieden sich von ihren familien
sie läuft an die mobilmachung am tag
eins nach putins befehl und dem wollen
offenbar viele entkommen stau an der
grenze zu georgien russen auf der flucht
vor dem krieg mit dem auto nach georgien
oder per flugzeug nach istanbul
die teilmobilmachung ist einer der
gründe warum ich hier bin es ist ein
furchtbarer schritt der zu vielen
problemen für russische bürger führen
kann
[Musik]
während die russische armee auf
verstärkung wartet wurde an der front
weiter heftig gekämpft und mitten im
krieg soll morgen in den besetzten
gebieten gewählt werden wie hier in
lugansk letzte vorbereitungen für das
referendum wie es die russen nennen die
menschen sollen darüber abstimmen ob die
region künftig zu russland gehört
darüber soll morgen auch in donetsk
abgestimmt werden hier explodierte heute
eine bombe auf einem marktplatz mehrere
menschen wurden getötet
aber es gibt auch eine seltene
annäherung dieser ukrainischen soldaten
waren monatelang in russischer
kriegsgefangenschaft und sind jetzt
wieder zurück in der heimat viele von
ihnen verteidigten das auf stahlwerken
mario pohl das wochenlang unter
dauerbeschuss stand es ist der größte
gefangenenaustausch seit kriegsbeginn
215 gefangenen wurden an die ukraine
übergeben russland hat im gegenzug 55
gefangenen erhalten
vereinzelte aktionen gegen die
teilmobilmachung gab es überall im land
die größten gestern abend in moskau die
polizei knüppelte die proteste nieder
ich habe söhne wir wollen mit niemandem
kämpfen wir wollen niemanden töten ich
möchte sie nicht als leichen
zurückbekommen
viele wurden festgenommen und offenbar
schon eingezogen und zum kriegseinsatz
in der ukraine gezwungen
waren wir unseren korrespondenten
christian wm in moskau wie groß ist die
chance dass sich diese proteste
ausweiten
das ist im moment noch schwer zu sagen
es ist zwar für samstag sind neue
proteste ausgerufen worden von der
menschenrechtsorganisation wesna wir
haben ja gestern hier selbst erlebt in
moskau wie brutal die sicherheitskräfte
dazwischen gehen wie brutal diese
proteste niedergeknüppelt werden und das
wird sicherlich viele menschen auch
davon abhalten und ihnen angst machen
auf solche
verbotenen proteste zu gehen das haben
wir gestern erlebt und das war ja auch
landesweit in vielen städten so
insofern ist das im moment noch schwer
zu sagen wie viele am ende diesem aufruf
folgen werden was fehlt ist auch ein
prominenter kopf der zu diesen protesten
aufrufen könnte die opposition ist eher
kalt gestellt worden in den letzten
monaten also die prominenten köpfe sind
entweder aus dem land gejagt oder sitzen
im gefängnis also es ist sehr fraglich
wie viele da jetzt am samstag teilnehmen
werden und selbst wenn es tausende
werden würden wäre das auch kein problem
für diesen massiven sicherheitsapparat
vielen dank für diese einschätzung aus
moskau christian semmeln
die eu hat als reaktion auf die
teilmobilmachung weitere sanktionen
gegen moskau angekündigt allerdings
stellt ungarn sich quer und fordert
sogar ein ende aller sanktionen
viel applaus bekam der ukrainische
präsident selensky nach seiner video
ansprache vor den vereinten nationen
seelands gefordert eine gerechte
bestrafung russlands außerdem müsse das
land wegen des angriffskriegs auf die
ukraine sein vetorecht im sicherheitsrat
verlieren aus new yorkerin
standing ovations für die video
ansprache des ukrainischen präsidenten
am abend in seiner rede hat der blogger
misa lynskey eine harte bestrafung
russlands auch durch die vereinten
nationen gefordert
solange der aggressor mitglied den
entscheidungsgremien internationale
organisationen ist muss er von ihnen
isoliert werden zumindest so lange die
aktion an
lehnt sein recht souverän ab entzieht
ihm das delegations und vetorecht
heute morgen dann sitzung des
un-sicherheitsrates auch die deutsche
aussenministerin ist eingeladen vor der
sitzung machte sie klar man habe keine
angst vor russischen drohungen man werde
die ukraine weiter wirtschaftlich und
militärisch unterstützen
das werden wir gemeinsam in der
sicherheitsratssitzung jetzt deutlich
machen
dass wir diesen angriff auf die ukraine
und den angriffe auf die friedensordnung
europas und die charta der vereinten
nationen nicht akzeptieren gleich zu
beginn der sitzung verurteilte der un
generalsekretär die jüngste große
eskalation rhetorik
die idee eines nuklearen konflikt
bislang undenkbar wird jetzt debattiert
das alleine ist völlig inakzeptabel
russlands außenminister lawrow
verteidigte das russische vorgehen mit
altbekannten argumente
wir haben kein zweifel daran dass die
ukraine ein totalitärer nazi staat
geworden ist die internationalen
menschenrechte mit füßen tritt die
direkte unterstützung durch den westen
macht den westen zu einer partei in
diesem konflikt
die fronten verhärten sich eine
friedliche lösung des konflikts wird
immer unwahrscheinlicher
sollte deutschland die ukraine noch
stärker unterstützen die union drängt
darauf weitere schwere waffen zu liefern
es geht unter anderem um den
schützenpanzer marder von dem könnte die
industrie nach eigenen angaben bis zu
100 exemplare bereitstellen oder der
kampfpanzer leopard 2 er gilt als einer
der besten seiner art 15 europäische
länder nutzen ihn mehr von mathis
feldhoff
tag eins nach putins mobilmachung wann
wenn nicht jetzt müsse man auch moderne
westliche panzer in die ukraine liefern
fragt die union und stellt das heute zur
abstimmung
jeder gepanzerte schutz der den soldaten
der ukraine fehlt sorgt für opfer sorgt
für verletzung sorgt für todesfälle am
morgen beim besuch des französischen
kollegen stellt die
verteidigungsministerin allerdings schon
klar dass deutschland bei seiner linie
bleibt
wir werden die ukraine auch weiterhin
auch weiterhin in ihren mutigen kampf
unterstützen und es drückt sich zb darin
aus dass ist jetzt auch gelungen ist
ganz aktuell den ringtausch zu
organisieren so liefert slowenien jetzt
28 m 55 im tausch gegen deutsche militär
lkw im parlament tut sich die ampel
schwer zwei der drei partner sind für
lieferungen schwerer waffen aber die
koalition sprengen will man nicht
wir als freie demokraten sind der
meinung dass wir in der jetzigen
militärischen lage in der die
ukrainische armee stück für stück ihre
territorium zurückholt mindestens den
transportpanzer fuchs und den
schützenpanzer marder liefern müssen wir
müssen schneller werden wir müssen
substanzieller werden alle miteinander
aber das werden wir zusammen dem bündnis
tun müssen der rechte und der linke rand
im parlament dagegen wieder mal
erstaunlich einig wie rutschen auf einer
schiefen ebene in die teilnahme an einem
konflikt der nicht der unsere ist genau
das ist das ergebnis der katastrophalen
politik der waffenlieferung nämlich eine
verlängerung dieses abscheulichen kriege
um den eklat in der koalition zu
vermeiden wurde der antrag am ende nicht
abgestimmt und in die ausschüsse
verwiesen
im bundestag heute auch eine ankündigung
von wirtschaftsminister habe wegen der
stark gestiegenen energiekosten erhält
die industrie demnach erweiterte hilfe
unterstützt werden sollen nicht nur
firmen im internationalen handel sondern
generell unternehmen die verluste machen
auch der mittelstand soll stärker
berücksichtigt werden die steigenden
energiepreise werden wir alle zu spüren
bekommen zeit sich zu überlegen ob man
vielleicht nicht doch beim heizen sparen
kann gerade im winter noch sind aber
nicht alle neuen gasrechnungen raus das
bedeutet noch ist das problem offenbar
nicht bei allen angekommen moritz neuss
der gaspreis auch hier in münchen
schnell nach oben viele sind
verunsichert machen sich sorgen ich spar
losgeht ich bade weniger und lasst die
heizung kalt im prinzip so wenig wie
möglich benutzen ganz klar der byrds
kessen nachzahlungen im vierstelligen
bereich um vorzubeugen wollen viele eine
modernere heizung mit seinem team baut
olaf zimmermann einen neuen kessel nach
dem anderen ein das verspricht 20
prozent weniger energie verlust wir
haben sehr viele anfragen die leute
wollen dass die anlage optimiert wird
das ding gar so brauch was sie jetzt
haben noch nie so zinkl wollen aber auch
nicht groß sage ich jetzt mal auf ihren
komfort verzichten offenbar seien viele
heizungen noch so eingestellt wie zu
vorkrisenzeiten kritisierte zuletzt die
bundesnetzagentur
privathaushalte hätten in den
vergangenen tagen sogar mehr verbraucht
als erhofft versorger mahnen jeder der
kann sollte energie sparen wenn wir die
raumtemperatur um ein grad nur
unterstellen dann spart das ungefähr
sechs prozent energie also es gibt auch
wirklich einfache möglichkeiten noch mal
weiß ich selber zu schauen ob man
energie einsparen kann energieberater
jürgen leppich fürchtet dass private
verbraucher das problem bislang noch
nicht zu spüren bekommen dieser
preisdruck es bei den privaten
haushalten noch nicht angekommen weil
die jahresrechnung nicht aber viele
haben auch noch ein vertrag mit dem mit
etwas günstigeren gastarifen ob es über
den winter zu einem gasmenge kommt hängt
auch vom privaten heizverhalten ab die
deutschen gasspeicher sind mittlerweile
zu rund 90 prozent gefüllt
in den iran dort starben seit freitag
mindestens 17 menschen bei protesten
trotzdem gehen weiter tausende auf die
straßen der auslöser ist der tod dieser
frau massa amini 22 jahre alt die
sittenpolizei hatte sie festgenommen
weil sie angeblich ihr kopftuch nicht
vorschriftsgemäß trug kurze zeit später
fiel sie ins koma und starb doch längst
geht es bei den protesten nicht mehr nur
um sie jörg brase und franziska von
tiesenhausen
auch in der vergangenen nacht gibt es
wieder proteste wie hier in der
hauptstadt teheran
tausende sind auf der straße auch sechs
tage nach massa amys tod app der
widerstand nicht ab es geht gegen den
kopftuchzwang gegen die sittenpolizei
gegen die konservativ religiöse führung
in sari stürmen demonstranten in der
nacht auf mittwoch ein
verwaltungsgebäude reisen die porträts
der ayatollah khomeini und kamine von
der wand unter dem jubel der menge
prominente frauenrechtlerinnen fordern
eine reform der islamischen
kleidungsvorschriften
ich bin für den hijab als persönliche
entscheidung aber gegen die pflicht ihn
zu tragen diese pflicht gibt es in
unserer religion nicht und sie verstößt
gegen unsere verfassung
religionsführer khamenei aber gibt sich
unerschütterlich in einer rede gestern
erwähnt er die proteste mit keinem wort
auch sein regierungschef sie hält eine
rede in new york vor der
un-generalversammlung
verbittet sich jede einmischung aus dem
ausland
in der konsequenz werden hier
verschiedene kommentare abgegeben zu
einem vorfall der von uns gerade erst
untersucht wird
untersucht werden soll ob die
sittenpolizei im falle von masse amini
ähnlich brutal vorgehen die auf diesen
bildern die sich im internet finden seit
30 amtsantritt werden frauen die ihr
kopftuch nicht vorschriftsgemäß tragen
wieder öfter von den moral wächtern
festgenommen viele hoffen dass die
proteste eine diskussion und vielleicht
auch veränderungen anstoßen
eigentlich wollten wir jetzt nach
teheran schalten zu unserem
korrespondenten jörg brase aber weil die
regierung dort das internet und offenbar
auch die satellitenverbindungen
weitgehend gekappt hat können wir ihnen
nur noch per telefon erreichen kurz vor
der sendung gab und seine einschätzung
[Musik]
und insofern greift man da sehr hart
durch das ist doch wieder zu beobachten
aber der punkt ist eben heißt auch dass
alle gesellschaftsschichten auch die
konservativen nach dem tod von nathan
familie erklärte stürzten und man davon
ausgeht dass die regierung darauf
reagiert auch reagieren muss und dass
viele formen eine lockerung vielleicht
kopftuchzwang es geben könnte das muss
man jetzt abwarten ob das tatsächlich so
passiert aber das scheint auch die
stimmung im moment zu sein
soweit jörg brase aus teheran zurück
nach deutschland die bundesanwaltschaft
hat im nordrhein westfälischen iserlohn
einen jugendlichen festnehmen lassen
unter dem einfluss der islamistischen
terrororganisation es solle einen
bombenanschlag in deutschland geplant
haben der deutsch kosovare habe sich
zunächst erklären lassen wie man einen
sprengsatz baut stattdessen habe er dann
einen messerangriff auf polizeibeamte
vorgehabt
es war ein kampf gegen die zeit am ende
konnten helfer in australien mehr als 30
grand für alle retten allerdings hat ein
großteil der etwa 230 tiere nicht
überlebt sie waren gestern an der küste
tasmaniens gestrandet
mit boten brachten helfer heute die
geretteten wale zurück ins offene meer
doch wissenschaftler sehen wenig
überlebenschancen für die tiere denn die
wale könnten versuchen zu ihren
gestrandeten
familienmitgliedern zurückzukehren
und jetzt fußball rabatte nations league
deutschland trifft morgen auf umgang ja
live zu sehen uns bei uns im zdf ab 20
uhr 15 hansi flick steam könnte durch
einen sieg die tabellenführung in der
gruppe übernehmen ein nachhaltiger
erfolg also wo doch gerade jetzt
nachhaltigkeit im team die ganz groß
geschrieben wird
sie hätten von frankfurt nach leipzig
auch das flugzeug nehmen können doch
nach kritik an solchen kurz flügen
zuletzt reist das nationalteam mit der
bahn so gewöhnungsbedürftig es auch sein
mag ich hoffe natürlich dass wir heute
das wäre natürlich schön pünktlich
abfahren können gehe ich einfach mal
davon aus und wir freuen uns natürlich
auf die flugreise auf die zugreise wie
auf schienen läuft die wm vorbereitung
nicht leon goretzka und manuel neuer
haben chor oder marc andré ter stegen
wird im tor stehen die zielsetzung vor
dem ungarn spiel bleibt gleich das wäre
natürlich ein statement will man hier
die gruppenphase holz erst das
abschließen könnten deswegen ist unser
ziel das haben wir im vormonat voran
gesagt wir wollen unbedingt in die final
four im hinspiel gab es ein
unentschieden timo werner wäre einer für
1 siegtor beim letzten heimspiel in
leipzig vor zwei jahren hat er zweimal
getroffen
bochum hat einen neuen trainer
verpflichtet thomas letsch soll den vfl
aus dem fußball bundesliga keller holen
der 54 jährige kommt vom
niederländischen erstligisten arnheim
und erhält einen vertrag bis 2024
erst die niederlage für die ukrainische
nationalmannschaft in der liga bäder
nations league das team verlor gestern
abend in glasgow die partie gegen
schottland mit 0 zu 3 jan musste auch
noch die tabellenführung an den gegner
abgeben ein abend den sich der
ukrainische coach alexander petrak oft
ganz anders vorgestellt hat die tore im
hampden park von glasgow fallen spät 70
10 minute john mccain lässt kiepert
rubin keine chance 1 0 für die gastgeber
schottland mit einer furiosen
schlussoffensive landon deix mit einem
präzisen kopfball das 2 0 in der 80
minute und der stürmer von den queens
park rangers hat noch nicht genug wieder
nach einer ecke wieder mit köpfchen 87
spielminute 13 0 der endstand die
schotten gewinnen nach einer souveränen
leistung in der zweiten hälfte am ende
deutlich gegen die ukraine
um den direkten aufstieg in die liga der
nations league einen herben dämpfer
erleidet
das war es auch schon vom sport und hier
gibts jetzt noch einen völlig neuen
blick auf neptun den acht planeten
unseres sonnensystems die europäische
raumfahrtagentur esa hat neue besonders
scharfe bilder vorgestellt deutlich zu
sehen die ringe aber auch linien auf der
oberfläche sie deuten auf wind und sogar
stürme auf dem neptun hin die bilder
stammen vom james webb teleskop das erst
im dezember ins all geschossen wurde
morgen im osten und süden hier noch
sonne die details hat gleich erst intern
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um 14 im
heute journal
wir wünschen ihnen einen schönen abend
noch und sind morgen wieder da auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon glaubte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter dieser sommer war europaweit
extreme es war der heißeste sommer ja
und diese hitze hatte auch eine
auswirkung auf die gletscher matthäus
hat uns dieses bild hier zur verfügung
gestellt erhält hier einen mesz starb in
der halle in der hand das über sechs
meter hoch ist und diese sechs meter an
ice sind am alex gletschern
concordiaplatz weggeschmolzen es ist
quasi ein leises sterben der gletscher
schon aus wetter und da gibt es nebel in
gewässernähe wieder nach osten hin und
auch an der donau temperaturen liegen
zwischen null und zehn grad und morgen
wenn die nebelbänke sich verzogen haben
wird es relativ freundlich vor allem im
süden deutschlands so nach osten scheint
die sonne häufiger nach nordwesten sind
die wolken etwas dichter aber insgesamt
trockenes wetter bei höchsten
temperaturen bis zu 23 grad im südwesten
deutschlands und 14 grad nach südosten
hin die nächsten tage am samstag kaum
schauer von westen her auf ansonsten ist
es nach osten hin noch trocken 15 bis 20
grad oder am sonntag gibt es sogar
gewitter ein schöner abend